the jurogan experience so here's my only
this is all i'm working on because
there's a whole slew of young people who
are just opting out and they're moving
to building parallel systems parallel
networks which is pretty much the only
thing you can do we have all the
technology everything we need
my two projects i bring them together
brought them together is podcasting that
is protected and bitcoin and and i'm
just on the bitcoin train because i
believe that
my money is safer there i'm not talking
about versus the us dollar
just in general and i think that that
does
i think that we will see that in our
future as
very um very protective for everything
you know as they say bitcoin fixes this
if you can fix the money which is that's
the broken part the money system is
broken it causes the inflation it causes
the misery it causes wars because it's
linked to the to oil so we have to go
protect all that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up
the dollar i i love america
we used to have our own
the banks would create dollars there
were promissory notes until this federal
reserve act came into play
it was a takeover that's what kennedy
was talking about the the power that is
unspoken by man
it's it's this banking system
if we continue to be in that we're just
[ __ ]
yeah and i have a lot of hope for
cryptocurrencies i really do i don't
know too much about them but bitcoin
seems to be the one in the ethereum the
ones that the people who are in the know
talk about the most and my point is that
what we're seeing right now it's either
going to go one way or the other it's
either going to fall apart completely or
we're going to use this as an
opportunity to right the ship and come
up with a better way to live our lives
it's one it's going to be one of the
other the fun the fundamental difference
just so i say it because otherwise
people beat me up
the difference between bitcoin and
ethereum is bitcoin there will only be
21 million it cannot be changed it
cannot be inflated you cannot say the
same for ethereum oh that's that's the
main difference also there's no ceo of
of bitcoin oh the ceo of ethereum well
there's there's if you look at the
history of it eventually changes
and that's going to be a problem well
once once someone you know interesting i
love nfts i've never done one i'm not
interested in it but you kind of know
how that works well you know there's one
from people well there you go yeah and
that this is fulfilling
klaus schwab's dream
is it yes
you will earn nothing and you will be
happy
so you get an nft i own you nothing and
i'm [ __ ] you on everything you own
plus you own an ft
it doesn't take away all your stuff no
you don't own it you don't own it it's
beautiful i love it it's like baseball
cards only you know
well or crazy but you do
because it's a non-fungible token adam i
know it is like i understand it yeah no
that's my thing now you nailed it now a
buddy of mine you know
these entertainment companies they're
doing so much money and these nfts on
you know their the intellectual property
that they already have you know just
even uh was it uh brian cox you know the
guy from sure yeah he's doing an nft he
is i'm not allowed to say what it is but
yeah
lamborghini is making an nft
the physical company why not get those
dummies to buy it yeah
well now now in the in the dream of the
metaverse
the silicon valley controlled metaverse
nfc is gonna be very very important
uh they'll all be with their own [ __ ]
coin you know they'll be like whatever
the the
meta coin will be
and then you have really more the
ethereum crowd who are building their
own decentralized metaverse but there
when you have a cool outfit that is one
of a kind you can trade it with someone
and you know you do that through an nft
that's a very valid reason if you're
into that do you think the future will
be companies will come up with a coin
and then you have to purchase
the company's products with that coin
like say if apple came up with its own
coin they seemed to be one of the few
companies that could easily do that
right if they decided to have an apple
coin no you'd buy all apple products
with an apple with apple phones apple
imacs and no you just invest in what do
you mean now hold please i'm going to
tell you let me hold please let me
finish that you let people invest in
being a part of the company so you buy
coins and through those coins you can
buy products and you can invest a
certain amount and the coins go up you
actually make money the coins go down
you lose money and as the company keeps
doing better it's almost like a another
version of stocks or something and you
buy it all through that is that possible
possible now all the way through sorry
it's a very bad house
i'm a [ __ ] know-it-all i'm very
excited you're smarter
you're excited to talk no i'm irritated
by myself i'm not i'm not here
don't worry about it
that's kind of what facebook wanted
right
yeah facebook had the the libra and it
was all set up and then uh the us
government intervened and said [ __ ] no
because that would become that could
easily become the default currency
overnight
facebook does facebook does all this
local commerce they own the classified
market they own the real economy you
know the small mom and pops they own
that [ __ ] which is why everyone hates
them especially the news people because
they're taking their salaries they're
taking their [ __ ] money away
newspapers oh my god anyway
that's not the plan
the plan is the central bank digital
currency you will have crypto you will
have a digital wallet it will be
directly from the federal reserve to you
and there will be no
little retail banking that just won't
happen anymore
all online
oh oh of course no more brick and mortar
in 50 years i mean no no
you you just use it like you you use
venmo now use the same way only be
connected to the federal reserve to the
central bank now you've been completely
morphed into where they want you to be
because then they fully control you
right but do you think they'll be retail
stores
you think they'll be retail right well
if you believe the
in the metaverse that neil stephenson
wrote about in snow crash which uh i
read actually i had i had metaverse.com
for a long long time is that it's no
crash that's not
that's not that film
isn't there a film called no piercer
that's no no no no no crash don't think
it's everything i would hate for it to
be filmed um the only thing left in in
meat space once we are live in the
metaverse
is uh
is um domino's pizza delivery and fedex
and hoverboards that's all that's left
in that order
pretty much
pretty much space i love that too yeah
yeah
space
yeah but you know there's i think
there's a real possibility
that um
how about this just for scenario you
know you're already in the gaming world
you kind of love it you know you got got
the goggles on it's augmented reality
it's virtual reality now maybe i can get
a gig you know maybe i can put on a
glove and do this and operate a robot
you know remotely in a factory somewhere
or maybe i can train artificial
intelligence basically training to get
rid of me
you know these are all things that i
believe is where silicon valley wants to
take us could you imagine if that was a
thing where you got a job in the
metaverse and through the metaverse you
were making things at a factory in a
room oh that's going to happen oh for
sure come on man elon's already jacking
into your brain of course this is going
to happen this is transhumanism this is
this is truly what one of the big
agendas is it will integrate people with
technology